може вони вже традиційно ok парі
перший національний запит я вас до у
льодового контактного центру
зараз знаходимося і самих сюди що дня
викликані до
щоб поставити ти , побачивши
team і сам цей рахунок та дружина ми з вами
зустрічаємося для того, щоб він примати
відповісти на ти, я хочу у вас є віспи
то ти і в ряду у просто на кіфу риту
око який фану це номер маревний
гарячий час і неприємний для вас вибір
що його на екрані 0 800 500 7 309
телефоні diving & easy стаціонарних
апаратів ваших українців близько штурму
черв'яки для багатих руди гаряча пора
гаряча пора для тих, хто хоче
продовжити і начальник після школи і все
ваші випробування keys тусуються про святі
всіх початкових захоплень ми адресуємо у за
раз міністру з питань свят і науки України
Дмитро Табачник увитій у вас цьому
дроїди лікарем доброго дня розхитався за
зовнішні на закладене оцінювання
на правду гаряча пора річки
особливу вас тятиву руку від ступнів
компанії кису влади мають рацію це не за
зовнішнього на заручника оцінювання скільки
завести рвалась
абітурієнтів користується хотів би сказати
ще суму роті триста двадцять дві
тисячі половиною васи виявив і бажання
ск вас ти сонячними закладеного
сьогоднішній цикл ще на 2 70000
випускники минуло їхні руки чисті різні
хоч і пофарбує есв результат то чоловік
гадаю все абсолютно вступники може
пред'являти та напади до університету
колишнього ще початкового закладу
результати тестів за всі руки.
з 2008 а годинник на просто змінила вибір
професії яка на хочеться but i
університеті їх тієї, з якими стати
біологам його немає з білою
від і первин плану і вступає і на
фізичні че радіофізичний факультет
і тому ж райздоров'я вся над туго не
зв'язати
за галон правило тестування та
стабільними та
центр ж важливі в цьому ще результаті ви
пробували на багатий менш стресові низ
поділені для тих хто складу та для
абітурієнтів розум стоїмо хотів би
сказати ще був і пам'ятай призначення
зміїний перше в тім рот новий предмет
люблять сигнали на неї за реєстр
тассі зі святого література
ціль від них хто хоче вступати і на
спеціальність з в'язання з філологією
обріс педагогіку іншої абітурієнти
виявив і обожнювання складу ти тести і дні
її змі ви початкових турелі qc малий
національних менше
васей ська угорського пошуку словацько
не втримає тетрадь завданням і позбавити її
умову і тоді повна свобода вибору
дитину яків чіпси в українській школі з
польську нові викладання може
здавати тести польську мою довга
коптиться в українській школі за
російську молу і викладання може
складу тієї тести
новація ми серйозно посилай контроль за
допомогу та міністерства внутрішніх
справа на пунктах для того не честь
не люди не користалися а з чо ти
вольна you апаратурою вчить
мобільними пристроями амітай коен йшов
раніше було 30 сотки пунктів
тестування обл 1 але ми-то вашу качани
і нижчими приводи маяки не дозволяють
пронес ти в аудиторію призму електрону
і казку такому роді мій же 75 сотки
псих аудиторій усіх пунктів тестування
буду обл 1 націями про і будуємо ну і
хотів би сказати ще звучали але самі за
харчуванням доз канали не і в 4-му, і
педагогами та t100 ларами та canon ними
проти ви в цілому можна сказати ще
першить їсть його не я з хімії пройшло
абсолютно успішно з ти хто
зареєструвався 91 висота прийшли націй
з 5 ніяких порушити nebula
ну і насправді зможе за значить ще
нас навіть ліберальніше на тій же парі поза на
з європою вправила тест у вані
проекту біг шоу у нас був вчений телефон
чекістам bluetooth хто з 4-го інформацію
то просто переривається тест і люди на не
зможе в тему роті матей результати
пригнаний із чоловіків вступати і до
університету у Франції на приклад
сонячному він викладом оцінювання хто
спеман її з апаратурою шпаргалкою
учні масть при будові табіб
відмовляти розбавляється наказом міністра
у свитої республіки франція право на 5
рокки в ступа ти до вищих початкових
законі я загубилася і темряву таких так
ось у дванадцятому уроці ми нову руку
153 молодих вигляд молодих людей із францією
потро поліції чорний наказ і утримати
про поступатися і французький університет
краще в лідку 2018 дорогу через п'ять
повних руки вище знайшов стануть вікінг
а у нас кілька ти зустрічаєшся можна її
сюди руку просто ця страва
результату і адже видно університет
наприклад тобі документи там шкоди
сертифікати та києва я почав часу твій
дізнайся азалії ось ви можете від'їхати
колись бестселери керчі фізики ось
потім і за заявою маяки подав і на
предмет і після зовнішнього я хочу сказати
помрете уві сні вперше навіть такі
позитивні результати кіно мою думку
світити про тещу з успенського по 3 та по
врізається до поінформування
ще краще я кисні інженерного свята
технічно ніш і як слабенько юридич
ночей економічна в не профільному
університеті на ebay шакірі кицьки я взяв
для склейки цінне пак по ширині я був
ризиковий тест тестове завдання 98
сотні всіх абітурієнтів замість
новолісине тестування з українською
мови та літератури не вперше за всі сім
руки у проведенні сонячний він і
закладеного оцінювання на інші місяці
адже ми ж 62 сотки обожнюючих вийшла
математика з маркування
обігнавши машина 2 адже сотки історію і
адже історія ступила на третю позицію
прощатися горе ще абітурієнт 2013 року
судячи з чистого якийсь тест евенського та й
Вінс це звичайно нічний світ і куди
залінковані і над їх ніч не на інженер
не професії з правильно там ще тримала
знайти prophecy більше вже третій пост
державний замок вода висловилася що
тіло річі абітурієнти відривав і може
вивести
яким від у б радий і за шахти з
приставаннями над тимонею окований
краще знають ось із змогла євро вистачає
зимівник обожнювання будуть абітурієнтів
знає і ми змогли ворог біля воріт і всьому
поза обожнюванням абітурієнту адже
видно і документі на нормативні закони
удавчик тату документики призначають на
ніяких нових видів цілого року
в українських школах хотів би сказати ще
в тему роль всіх блазень запивайте маси хто
обожнюю я вже сказав триста двадцять дві
з половиною тисячі то приблизно трошки
можна менше 20 сотки
захопив і висоти тетрадь його тримають і
писати та тестові завдання на цих а
найсильніших momax заарештувати 900 км
звучання на ebay shaquille їсть
абітурієнтів вибрав і російському мало
їй польська угорська кримськотатарська
словацьке таким же хочу сказати ще у
нас і на прикладну ділові ніякі
випадки колони дикі абітурієнти просто
ньому я розповім як кують стримав саме
при кладці видно абітурієнт називати його
руку зареєструвався і ви і ви в
бажання один тест pisa ти за нову в
кримському татарську нову другу тест
угорську та 3 пошуку і на логічно і за
харчування для чого ці роботи інтереси
одне все ніби нікуди не вступаю я
просто хочу перевертає is very війни
зайнятися їх мовляв меншою молодою людиною
до київського він прийшов тестування
реєструвався в секторі тести на
кримсько-татарський мій його за python
вітчизною ж ти розуму у нини знаю а для
чого ці роботи а я хочу продано суворо
ти таким чином
ну свою солідарність і been trying
українському татарському народу я думаю що
це не те мова не спекотною там ще випад
дещо приходить такі абітурієнти
польше тримав це чай бюджетників
наприклад секцій поставити на іншого не
тестових матеріал
а клімату вояк шеллак ні прийшов на
київські пункт лист увальня то для неї
треба крем перекладати шануй все і а
крім кабінет або я буду
знаємо відсоток ледве інструктори тубту
ніжний і кажу про перикла просто за цілий
день і його розмах треба
двом людям кинуть і всі і виплати їм
зарубає ну а нам усім на розвиток
розвалі
ну спочатку міністерство святі ну-ка
на мага і цілі кімнати здоров'я по
бажання by 6 абітурієнтів я думаю ще
доступну руку ми вниз йому вже в морзі в
правил шукаю тут на людину може вибору
ти
на всіх тесті ту маяку його на володиною
адже до фіналу
алексом і побачимо вухах тобто вище один
тест уральську інші польські треки
словацьку 4 кримськотатарського c не будемо
у дозволять це чоловікові на виток що ціни
відповідай на талона випий поліглот і я
дорого задорого even все-таки я кусь мовляв
знаючи найкраще будь ласка
продемонструє свої знання на кіа кід
його логічні тиш дошка багато броні
шивон не одноразово дорікала на 1000
старшокласника з саре джонс вище рад
їх предмети і ки потрібно здавати ти
частий стілець вони і не заражаються сином
бал атестата чімін його ситуація в
зірок густим чекає повернулася від
освіти середнього балу а то я думаю
3 змінилося а середній бал і статус
то volum їм
та результат накопичення знань умільці
результати пипець сунув і 11 руки в
проти середньої школи
вивчаючи але як і раніше можна було на 3
тестах зарубіж і 600 балів apisto
віддавав всього до 12, то ви напали спокійно
скорочуючи з підручником за репетитором з
займаються тільки trama предметами
наберу на кожному здогадами 5 балійців
а 15 на речами не тане і 120 ту балони
пісня-то і до десятої роти ми підсіли
раху ватою від is that the core за 200
болю в пера хуец а просто за спеціальною
таблицею акаїв кожен школярки навіть
просто те змінилося наше не
старшокласники таки завелася
чоловіки звістку попросила ти і на копи 4
бали у продаж навчальний в середній
школі з вугіллям старших класах з кути
його в інших класах базової школи
на відвозі 8 9 та старшу школу 10 та 11
гвинтів з абсолютно to reckon in ще c і
коло до соціальної справедливості.
не ти носила з маленького населеного
пункту знай за можна і рубаний вона не
може вбити дозволить і займатися з
репетитором і то пак репетиторами
столичними че там місця мільйони як all
i wanna телком може
своєю про цією своєю на підлогу і владою,
не ванни та систем незнання та
продемонструє і приніс 30200 болю в
завальний купіть не а вступ як і
минуло руку я типу заміну la russie вище
начальни закладаю україни навіть просто
c бали від і стату та 3
результати тесту вони адже видно
прибрані спеціальності топ дек шут їдеш
на фізику на спеціальність з в'язаних
інженерними інженерними науками
топ торт а я буду українська мова
література відразу мило і втв будемо a time
attack та фізика і що ти на
біологічний факультет
правди вступає і потім і особистого
університету на тему буде вид-во неї
основою та літератури і буду хімія та
біологія
плюс бал атестата і ось усієї лінійки
то європі що можна набрати 700 балів
наших тобто травня абсолютно
фантастичні знання краще і приховати
будемо від і 200 болем так от якраз
дитину та каменем ояму жвавості but i пити
тягнуть її репетитором вона за брати
школі вже за рублі і там блейз по 200
болі та
дуже багато обкрадених випускники вс
сільських шкіл приносять високий бал
атестата
і хочеш всі розвинені одну так багато ти
качку газет ну ще кожну руку з великі
c кільки з міду листям ми спеціально
провели аналіз за 20 руки кільки з міду
листя завищується практично стабільну
однак у сиро кікал є просто
скинь пензлем випускники 11 клас клімату
хоч би їх сказати і кожним так думає і
не паховим опонентом
менших політичних то буримо ще медаль
і золото з рівно ланцюг просто морально
адже знака з пам'яті роду і знайти пишайся
батьки у бабусі через силу і так і інша
допомогою ви нам набридли яскравих прикладів
подобається в ступі та ще початкового за
куди
за витягне кому дно і що абсолютно однак
еболою та за результатами тестування та
ось до речі ну абсолютно до 10 то в
такому виродку на 1 та місяці бюджетних
моя перевал проекту моя медаль
ну і й найголовніше ще хотів би
сказати ще навіть часто буває так все
тепікін і мають медалі мою без високих
бали від з то тут йому що ми дали
утворюється за астані три руки на
вчення і що скажемо а порожнина всі оцінки
мають бути для медалей вище 10
шорти стати це mp5 частіше з чисел a
thing 10 і золотом і даль а в корпусі
результати 11 12 зірок вони класи він і
півні атестат і в ньому а бал атестата
не скажемо у 196
автоперегонах я золото медаль 179 топ то не
спекулює та на ми дали США але назовні та
опоненти
ми далі просто результат брати навіть
великий у кельні годинник і c просто
моральний захоче якимось підвищується і
випускних шкіл та його ради від висловив і
протікання чого мови на ну це я так
думала відчуття бікінців та що ви не
75 років сотки - і світі скрипить і адже
сотки в пункті в наданні
металу шоку ніж ми і там комарам і
видос по країні я так розумію
від респондент когось і нові гарячі лінії
до янкі, які на путін дуже вогонь
категорій проходить приставання вона , ніж
ви ікла така необхідно шину на
катерина петровна цілий коконат їм щоб
ваша донька мало однак і могла влада
справедливіше і путін продуманий суворіше
ясна свої влада незнання мало потрібні
виступить і вище початковий закон колоди
на стіні you
молоді люди на ікони чесно приходить з
4 маленькими телефонами мчить на адже в роки
не залишають такі ліхтарики слизькі
штучки і потім через bluetooth передають
так можуть і номер завдань оправлена
побачити а ви хочу сказати ще
дієвих чистіше
пункти приставання обладнання
металу шу качани та камерами з поста
народження али
для тих хто хоче поманіпулювати
energy чому там ще у нас підписаний
стильний наказ із міністром внутрішніх
право захарченка і є спеціальні
таким убили не паріс у неї бригади та
кінозали але це будуть проходити їх ситом
через металу шукати він і будуть приходити
і пити годину вже голу перед початком
проведення сонячний він виклав
оцінювання і ви berkova по веденому лиж
і
їм графіку парі миль від них
аудиторії на я внести електронні чирику
і синю апаратури не хочу на гадот ще
адже не те що що мобільний
телефон буде і приз 3 налити wing
не просто вижити рішень сума ндс в
піджаку як поршні з грубої доручення
яйця люди на буде видав і на аудиторії
для проходу this tool вони й не втримають
правило в ціну роті вступала ти думаєш
про початок на закон але абітурієнти злилися
на підлогу і new від ремонту сип провал
проведення зовнішнього на заклав
оцінювання також бажають знати і своєю
правої ось будь-якої води колоди та сум
навіть зловиться ти і все їй і синові при
частої остигання раб там стани злі то
чому дорівнює розмаху висновок і треба до
такого сесію я хотів би сказати
очевидних державних му проведення ти
стільця не буди дитину
може за датою заяву на ставок бід та дні
після пристання іскра, що отримав убо
цей документ який засвічу ніж його на
не смола з класним тестом вони цілими
особисто давид kc і бувають минуло руками
допускав і таким чином дітей, кого
тропіло сімейно трагедія люди принесли
зведуть питання світі класикою і любин і
будиночку протягнемо день
тест звільняли збували похорон виразки
чайного коди nokia light такими ласі
такий же я там віддалена як будемо від ядро
ведучого на дії захопила і дарує
купу бажина він тримає з ранку до 11 о
довгих дантисту вони кашу скажемо 5
червня
знайдеш масове тіло не з українською
мови та літературі дві сесії 5 6 черні та
для того, що ці документи путін був
ізара howo її центри розрубати з ранку
евграфович та дантисту вонища плюс 4 днів
тобто продовжу 5 днів
подається заявок на регіональний центр і що
документ єдино справжній напевно
для докладніше яйця перебирається такий самий
магічний встановити те ті давального
тримати доступ до туди такі сесії
тесту вони нібито до дроту тисяч 4 по 11
посмішку мене на початку 2013 року
він в міністерстві заявила, що через
активних для проведення зовнішнього
на за належного tenue вони так і 10
мільйонів гривень відпочинок бюджеті порибачу
але ночувати менше ось але проблема в
вирішив ми розв'язав цю проблему xi на південь
і дні наші підганяють документи
у міністерстві фінансів бюджетному
комітеті Верховної Ради і можна запивати
ще всі доходи по в'язанню за зовнішніми
лижним оцінюванням наших абітурієнтів
будуть профінансовані в каннині
повному апсиді для тіла міністерство
перевезення робила фінансові потоки а при
корекції бюджету ми таверни та multicast
з мекі і взяв із менших статей тут-то
хочеш і гуркіт тестування
фінансового проблемами за зброю
питає не раз пачино і тебе прийом
заявка документів відступники
до вищих начальник захопивши ось і
фігурі чиж & co процедурою ці
нововведення
судно компанія з поділася буде такою
прозу раю стабільну та безконфліктну до
минуло руку
зміну руку не було практично ніяких
піднімуть і позаштатних ситуацій хотів би
сказати тисячі глядач треба державних
розуму в прийомі створі не і
зареєстровані в міністерстві всі
правила прийому ці розрубаю я шкірний
ваще початковий закуп міністерством жест
варив оперативний штаб
пройшов іп незвичайна дієти урядова лінія
буде консультаційний пункт для бочки в
абітурієнту
але ви позбавляєтеся стабільними для
вступник на навчальний заклад треба по
дати 3 сертифікати з балами тесту вони
адже поведено предмети
до тієї спеціальності на річку ти хочеш
вступати та атестат шкіряних абітурієнтів
уроку ми ж подати заявку
простуд і брат і доля конкурсі та 5
університетах причому в у кожному
університеті на 3 спеціальностей таким
чином фактично на шкірі над стусанами
дуже вступіть на бюджетні місяці
цей закон тракту
він нам уже брат і врахувати 15 конкурсів
дуже добре
документи будуть прямо тася 31 день поспішаючи
по 31 липне ключ на всі рази кликаю на
і божої волі ти особливо батьки you in
і на мага тиса в перший день у
боярського до 10 та води на ранку з датою
документи думаєш я читку знаючі
15 університеті ФДЕ буду вілли качера c
київський національний університет
шевченка циклічного політехніка
національний авіаційний університет
києві
львівський університет франко харківський
національний університет імені Каразіна
спраги шкіряний рік там відвалюються в
усмішці череп а хто хоче за галу зовуща
дати груші та тварини там девін
підіймається в 4 скоро стане і всякими
нову руку
електронним правом на ступі дена тремтів
на електрон
база вас вигляд і хотів би сказати ще
минуло muratti 67 тисяч абітурієнтів
скоро стала сили США
електронні системи та неясних проблемний
малі і ви себе паба 4 на сайті
університету в рейтинговому списку
d-wave видмухається зоря вашої балик
шахта є забрав документи вин знака їх
тобто додався з бути високими
балами
адже так може і з'являється
з'являється на списку ви ще у нас і
хотів би сказати ще ми всім урвати
цвіркунів у нього 10 ну 350 360000 у ступні
купці з депо графічними поки що знайомий і
освічені вартість тонни ступи в
минули руки
an edit але диснея знаю вже шкірок річок
приблизно 10 універ стати єдиною
окультист за ялтан завжди в porsche 2-3
днів до секс пінкод але all ще розповім
абсолютно однак і права і ти хто подав
електронну заявку цих ту пудів перша
усмішки та 5 і 20 абсолютно однак у
і цельсія на звучання сувора
контролюється міністерством контролю
особи граматика міс пустирі ночами та
і просто на брата пробачиш я розумію
сюди і сидить надлишком і хоче поїхати і
адже по чомусь і сам через виникають
черні
але я вам хочу сказати ще найменше
було заявлено уроку до національного
університет імені шевченка а в цьому
процесі ми ж 1008 у прайм вони комісії
і
домагаються ванни з вирубаною якумо краще
просто треба треба
ворог а ось ще 1 інші третини до нього не
буду ясна на бюджет його
а я кого означає і кілька ступня kenzo
державним за молла немитих хто владним
кішкам оплачу мовчання
вам адресою я по ній анжеліна з макіївки
донецької області
я хотів би ж povestea жилин ще
тремтів і за блискавку за твої жита та кабінет
міністрів після таєць його виробляється
міністерством економіки міністерством
фінансів і шалено міністерському святі та
тут просто жриця головному це держава
чека ламається менше місяця і замовляє
вони ви робить і нате професійний
найбільшими одній руці дні з технічнішим
інженерний металургія варити ж я цифри
дали державний за молвинець йому руку
ванну вже за твердіший на посту новий
кабінету міністрів вигляд 20 травня висловлював
на замок ладно на бакалавра тут-то
перший четвертий курс та товщини берсику
адже ми ж 123000 місяць державної за
блискавки фахівців ланцюга вступаючи на
програму фахівець після чотирьох
університетських російським студенткам ж я
тримав на забування 63
1885 ми ж 64000
і клімату вода іржаве замовляє дня на
магістратуру 41000
і що говорить і про можуть шо фахівець
20 дітей типу дмуть коледж і утримати
дипломи кращого фахівця з еммою ж
77000 навіть він і забув на мою думку
держава складала абсолютно щедро там
ще дикшу по ревниво ти 11-класників то
їх у тому уроці на цьому зайвим тисяч
менше нижньому ло отримав і за мого не
менше і на прямі знак 4000 в
абсолютних цифрах той хто конкурс став у
світі широким ну фактично на 3000 а
місяця ти хто хоче навчитися за
контрактом
не ви значитеся ліцензій у кожного
університету там чітко написано heaven
можна прикладати його ти там 50
інженерії у теплоенергетиці
знаю там трицепси державний zamyla я
почне по видно за контрактом мін чоловіка
на брат і 20x і можна переклали ти і c і
матеріали розміщені на ніжках прямо льне
комісії пиля пішов і пня буде кий
абітурієнт з батька ми через друзі ми
можемо давида тес прим вони комісії які
буду приблизно конкурс особі лавин просто
випробувай скільки нести у вас державного
за блискавку на таку спеціальність на таку
парі мене зрадив і мороком і таким чином
зможеш вкладіть свої сили я кладу ж
відмотаємо володимира вчаться вигнати але
розмел дякую я з подяваю ще писано
наші та розмиви та
та абітурієнтам та батькам буду белль
спокійно запит ору ступню компанію тер
руку що але мені добре справі ви так
може апастово ти, та просто онуки і
ряду та їжу від цього фону це поряд у
гарячу лінію в вона для тебе 0
800 500 7 309 здогадаюся, що він вважав і
фон твинки ці стаціонарних апаратів
без чого мені таку за увагу інших а його
she did i was to chew іншим розумному та
присвяченого опор спад тил і стануть
реальністю буває